un sujet de curiosité quand même en
berger pas un mot pas un seul mot du
chef de l'état depuis le vote des
français par en roumanie en moldavie et
demain après le conseil des ministres ça
ne m'intéresse pas ce second tour je
crois qu'il s'est d'abord exprimé avant
le premier tour pour redire très
clairement aux français qu'ils avaient
besoin d'une majorité d'une majorité
donc absolue pour agir je pense qu'elle
aura l'occasion de le redire évidemment
cette semaine vous savez qu'il est
présent de la république et qu'il exerce
par ailleurs la présidence aussi l'union
européenne ce qui impose aussi un
calendrier qui est parfois un peu
contraint et je ne doute pas qu'il dire
très clairement la nécessité que nous
électeurs se remobilise plus qu'ils ne
l'ont fait au premier tour de cette
élection législative de manière très
claire on a eu une forme de
démobilisation en tout cas une
mobilisation insuffisante rien venir et
que pour l'instant nous devons à mai
alimentant valley sur emmanuel macron à
un moment parce que brigitte lavaud
poser toutes les questions sur les
scrutins mais il semble le président
avoir du mal à organiser la riposte
c'est le sentiment qu'on a il est il est
aujourd'hui est un enjeu majeur pour lui
c'est d'obtenir une majorité il n'a pas
dit un mot il a fait déjà une campagne
en pointillés précédemment il va prendre
la parole vous nous le dites ce soir je
pense qu'il s'exprimera évidemment celle
des jeux le métal le souhaite et je
pense qu'en effet c'est indispensable
parce que le président de la république
à partir du moment où les élections
législatives ont lieu après l'élection
présidentielle est évidemment celui qui
à un moment donne l'impulsion nécessaire
et définitive pour mobiliser notre
électorat nous fait pas d assez d une
nécessité qu'ils puissent évidemment
s'exprimer comme il l'a fait avant le
premier tour pour marteler l'enjeu qui
est celui de ce scrutin une majorité
pour le président de la république un
risque de majorité relative a donc ce
risque d'instabilité voire pire le
risque d'une majorité pour l'extrême
gauche dans notre pays brive est bouché
c'est un mot valise avait devant soir
aurore bergé vous êtes au coude à coude
avec la nuque quand on regarde les
résultats d'hier soir c'est l'alliance
de toute la gauche et on voit aussi que
vous perdez trois points par rapport au
score d'emmanuel macron au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle est-ce que
vous avez été désavoué par les électeurs
je pense pas qu'on puisse parler de
désaveu déjà parce qu il faudra regarder
surtout le second tour c'est-à-dire la
capacité qu'on a envoyé des
parlementaires d député à l'assemblée
nationale et à former du coup cette
fameuse majorité d'un avertissement là
quand même qu'on vous a un jeu adressé
oui je pense qu'il faut le prendre comme
tel un avertissement sur la nécessité de
se mobiliser de démontrer qu'on a en
campagne matin midi et soir en campagne
sur le terrain en campagne aussi
médiatique pour porter les messages qui
sont les nôtres sur l'urgence à agir et
agir vite sur les questions essentielles
sur les questions de pouvoir d'achat sur
les questions de santé sur la transition
écologique et puis on a aussi une clarté
finalement dans cette élection on avait
une clarté dans la campagne
présidentielle avec deux blocs qui
s'affrontaient et là on a deux autres
blocs aujourd'hui qui s'affrontent la
majorité présidentielle et l'extrême
gauche on voit qu'il ya eu des facto une
atonie une disparition d'un certain
nombre d'autres formations vous dites il
faut montrer aux français qu on fait
campagne est-ce que ça a été l'erreur
finalement de cette campagne d'avant
premier tour de ne pas avoir fait assez
campagne nous on l'a fait sur le terrain
manière évidente sont à 577 candidats
qui se sont déployées on à 421 candidats
qui sont qualifiés pour le second tour
et qui donc lille domaine national pour
jour toulouse elisabeth avec un 1
emmanuel m'a conquis entrée tardivement
en campagne et en même temps on a senti
nous sur le terrain que juste après
l'élection présidentielle y avait une
forme de faillite des électeurs qui
n'avaient pas envie qu'on reparti
immédiatement en campagne et qu on les
remet aux yeux de jean-luc mélenchon
finalement ça a fonctionné c'est à
fonctionner sur une fable ça a
fonctionné sur un mensonge cette fameuse
élection du premier ministre et on voit
bien quand même vous sourit un joli et
politiques non non mais est ce que jean
luc mélenchon est habile politiquement
j'en ai jamais douté et en effet il le
prouve à nouveau certes la question
c'est que au delà de l'habileté
politique et du coup politique c'est
quel est le discours de jean luc
mélenchon et quel est le projet surtout
qu'il défend et defacto la manière avec
laquelle il a asphyxié les autres
formations politiques de gauche qui ont
renoncé à des éléments qui étaient des
éléments de principes qu'ils avaient
pourtant défendu de manière assez
acharné pendant la campagne
présidentielle de cette alliance elle
tient et jean luc mélenchon
j'obtiens de qu'elle meure et la premier
ministre vous vous y croyez il peut
encore être premier ministre croit
absolument pas je n'ai jamais cru qu'il
puisse l'être et je ne crois pas qu'il
pourrait l'être c'est pas le sens de nos
institutions c'est pas notre mode de
fonctionnement et aujourd'hui c'est vrai
qu'on a plutôt 12 éventualité soit une
majorité absolue soit une majorité
relative pour vous l'option d'une
majorité absolue pour jean luc mélenchon
aujourd'hui au regard du nombre de
candidats qualifiés me semble
heureusement tu es devenu en 10 2010 est
la majorité donc la république en marche
à l'époque il n'était pas majorité avait
obtenu était en tête dans quatre
circonscriptions et finalement vous
finissez avec un peu plus de 300 le
rapport de force il peut éventuellement
complètement s'inverser là où ne serait
que dans un second tour c'est une autre
campagne qui s'ouvre parce qu'on passe
parfois de configuration vous aviez 10
12 14 candidats voire plus qualifiés aux
pharaons candidats sur un scrutin
législatif à 2 il ya très peu
triangulaire il y en a eu huit cette
année en avait une seule en 2010 est
donc il ya vraiment que tu es duel
aujourd'hui qui existent mais le sujet
encore une fois c'est le projet
politique qui est porté la force que
nous nous avons c'est que le projet
politique que l'on porte il est le même
depuis la campagne présidentielle à ce
que dit jean luc mélenchon encore une
fois hier soir il pêcha parole jay et il
dit il ya un projet caché d'augmentation
de la tva mais d'accord sans en venir à
9/11 déficit vous avez un projet caché
bien sûr que non ça c'est le nouveau
sujet c'est la nouvelle tentative de
jean luc mélenchon il ya plusieurs
tentatives depuis hier soir 1 les
résultats ne me plaisent pas donc il dit
que les résultats sont truquées ce qui
est quand même un vrai problème dans la
vie démocratique de remettre alors il
s'appuie aussi j'ai le calcul des
journalistes du monde ça lui donne des
évidemment un argument supplémentaire
est extérieur à son discours c'est
amusant mais enfin je trouve même plus
amusant je trouve ça dangereux parce que
les candidats qu'ils remettent en cause
les résultats d'une élection
démocratique on en a connu d'autres dans
d'autres démocraties et ça c'est pas
forcément bien finie quand on regarde
notamment aux états unis
[Musique]